let's get this
set up sorry i'm a couple minutes late
apologies
i'm i'm planning to try and do some
shooting
um after this and i
decided to start putting um my makeup on
and let me adjust
sorry lighting adjustments ah
deal with this uh
i think that's a bit better yes
um the problem is the phone
this really does get washed out
go with that yeah
yeah that'll work so uh hey
folks um so this one is gonna be and i'm
gonna continue
to shift stuff around because i'm
annoying like that welcome to my stream
so yeah this is going to be a fairly
standard uh
ama and since i am doing
an ama and basically opening a free for
all for
whatever questions folks want to ask i
am going to uh adhere a little stronger
to
you are you may have to ask your
question more than once because i am
going to lose track of the questions as
they come in
i guarantee it and pretty much
the only thing that's going to guarantee
that i
see your question is going to be doing
it as a super chat
i don't want to sound like i'm holding
interactions with me to hostage but
i'm just being realistic on that so
let's see
did you hear about eddie van halen uh no
do
do i want to know starting the stream
with a growl
[Laughter]
um i'm afraid to ask what's up with
eddie van halen
and he died ah
that's i mean that's a shame i
i'm not really a van halen fan so that i
don't have a
personal connection to that but
obviously he's
he's some he's uh someone who's music
meant a lot to a lot of people
uh what are your thoughts on dr sleep i
haven't seen it so i don't have any
how many times have you seen rocky
horror i have no idea
at this point i couldn't even i couldn't
even guess
dozens
he was 65. i mean that's
that's kind of young broadly speaking
but i feel like for
by rockstar standards especially coming
from the era of rock and roll
that was his heyday i feel like that
that sounds about right it wasn't
exactly a gentle living i would suspect
how's tricks tricky
i have wanted you to stick with the
jenny nicholson-esque lighting
uh i don't i don't watch enough of her
stuff
to even really fully know what that
means
i've seen like a couple of things from
her um
i just never really dived in all that
hard favorite halloween movies not the
franchise just movies you enjoy around
the holiday
um see the thing is i don't
really have that many um
movies that are like staples of
halloween for me halloween is about
cartoon special so like
the peanuts halloween special the
garfield halloween special
uh the um real ghostbusters episode when
halloween was forever
those are my halloween staples as
opposed to movies
uh that's not to say i don't watch
spooky movies but none of them are like
traditions must do's
uh the way those things are that i
mentioned been watching gotham season
one
why did you hate barbara in season one
halfway through the series so far i'm
just questioning her choices
so okay um
barbara in season one for the first half
of season one at the very least
was just the nagging plot device
girlfriend
she was there to get in trouble and to
drive the plot or force the characters
into certain circumstances that
you know made it so they couldn't do
what they needed to to get crap done
like she was annoying and made very
stupid choices now
i should be clear by the time the show
was done barbara was one of my favorite
characters
so stick with it but early on boy i
hated her
i really did i was played eddie
in a production of rocky horror have you
seen phantom of paradise
um i'm aware of it i have not seen it
do you like the beatles music i like it
fine
i'm not as uh enamored with it
as a lot of people my age or older are
which doctor who episode has improved
the most
with your re-watch views um it might be
fires of pompeii i never really disliked
that episode but i've come to
really appreciate that one a lot more on
the rewatch
uh favorite film favorite film of all
time is ghostbusters
thoughts on the money python films life
of brian's their best work
i stand by that
have you seen the trailer for the
witches reboot yeah
i mean other than like kind of on some
of the cgi it seemed
fine i don't have that much investment
in either the original source material
or the previous adaptation so i'm like
whatever disney making sequel to the
lion king remake what are your thoughts
i mean
on the one hand i get it because like
they
they sunk all this r d into the tech
that went into the jungle book and the
lion king
and now that it's been developed and
streamlined a bit
they want to keep using it you know
it it's it's why it's becoming you know
increasingly common for them to do
things like dh actors in the
marvel movies and whatnot they've
perfected the
technology so they might as well put it
to use
so like i i have a tendency to think
they couldn't think of any other way to
continue using the tech other than to do
a sequel prequel i'm hearing mixed
things i don't know and i don't care
for the lion king i mean here's the one
thing i'll say
no sequel to the photo realistic
i refuse to call live action because
it's not
but the one thing that i will say about
um the photo realistic
lion king that a sequel would not
irritate me as much as the original
because the original
it the the first one was
adapting something that was so tightly
done and just
doing it all worse whereas with the
sequel it's either going to be some kind
of ad
adaptation of the later stuff done with
lion king or
more likely maybe a couple of elements
for those and then something new
so it's not going to tick me off as like
you took a perfectly good story and
screwed it up
so i still don't think it'll be
necessary but you know
uh do you meditate no
[Laughter]
do i meditate
i have atd i can't
i can't i've tried i can't i cannot
quiet my brain that's not how it works
i wondered if flying king getting a
sequel to the remake could also be due
to the pandemic
since it's probably the closest thing
they can make to
live action for the time being um
it's hard to say like i would imagine
that given the high-end uh workstations
that the animators have to be at
that the social distancing you have to
do for your animation
team you can't just stick them all in
cubicles right next to each other i
can't imagine that that's
that much less difficult than working
out a
socially distanced movie shoot i don't
know
funniest gravity falls moment for you
funniest for me
oh
i don't know probably something from
seuss
somewhere along the lines uh with the
live-action binge have you noticed that
the mouse seems to refuse to touch snow
white
i mean i hadn't take taken note of that
but
i mean part of that probably has to do
with the fact that if we're being
completely honest snow white
is a incredibly important seminal
technical
achievement it's not great
so and also snow white is a story that
has been retold elsewhere
repeatedly a lot of the disney things
especially
from like disney renaissance on their
versions have kind of become at least in
the us
the version that people know and think
of
so with things like little mermaid
aladdin beauty and the beast
where something like snow white i mean
like the disney version is important but
just to my thinking about i feel like
they don't have the same sense of
ownership
about it oh maybe that's me
do you watch trans youtuber samantha lux
i am unfamiliar with her so no
life of brian has a better overall story
but holy grail is funnier and more
quotable
agree on the first point politely
disagree on the second
holy grail is great don't get me wrong
i think life brian's funnier he's not
the messiah
he's a very naughty boy
do you believe the theory of dipper
pines being trans and gravity falls
i am unfamiliar with that theory so
that's a new one for me do you lift
weights
no
honest question now do i look like i
work out
because i don't think i do but also
i know that i don't so
i don't know maybe i maybe i look like i
work out
i don't so i wouldn't think that i would
but
uh whatever since you have brick box
have you watched spitting image i
haven't
not familiar with it uh do you watch
king of the hill
no i saw it sporadic episodes here and
there
but it never really really grabbed me
worst musical adaptation to film mine is
into the woods to me the movie didn't
have the impact
and it was needed in order to truly
understand the point of the story the
reason
into the woods didn't work is because
the entire stage show pivots on the
uh intermission and movies don't have
them
and it means the flow doesn't work
but yes i agree that one's very bad uh
do you watch shoe drama i mean i did
when it was still on
i've seen all of it i have a
uh planet express
sticker on my car it's on the gas cap
uh or the little lid uh for the gas tank
favorite quote what like just in general
i don't know don't let the bastards get
you down
i don't know uh i love it if in your
videos from now on you're lifting
weights i would have to get weights
first
like even for props i don't have weights
in my
house i'd have to like do curls with the
axe or something
uh unless you count running to be
working out i mean
it's exercise but when i think work out
i think like
getting on machines and like yeah
no like
i running is exercise but i don't think
of it as working out
what did the humans ever do for us um
asides from the sanitation the the
medicines the education the public roads
uh do you practice mindfulness
not consciously
welcome to the gym of geeks yeah right i
think the gym of geeks would just be
like um speed typing to [ __ ] on
internet forums
my audio series is finished and uploaded
congratulations
happy for you i think another thing with
snow white is the issue of the
non-consensual kiss
also digging the flannel thank you like
it's
it's fall it's flannel season as far as
i'm concerned
hardest dumbbells you find me some and
i'll start lifting them
what are your thoughts on tim burton's
sleepy hollow
it's fun it's pretty brainless
but it's fun favorite historical period
you'd like to travel to none of them
because i prefer the romanticized
versions that i get in
media i don't think i'd actually want to
find out the reality of any particular
historical time period
meditation doesn't have to be
concentrating on one single moment help
my adhd to let my mind wander
to whatever it feels like i mean like i
i do know i know enough about meditation
though it doesn't have to be completely
about clearing your mind but like i just
i am calm when moving around
that's that's just kind of a thing ted
danson is the dream lord yay or nay
interesting pick personally no but
interesting choice thoughts on
beetlejuice fun movie
aw that movie's a lot of fun do you
believe doctor who is underrated or
overrated neither
i believe it is rated
i have a friend in rome who's oh god
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna read that
all out
castile because i don't want to get
demonetized
uh you're not the messiah you're a very
naughty insert pronoun of choice here
love that love that
uh oh
having are you having fun ms wicked wolf
typing that out i think that's the
second or third time you've done it
i'm i'm not gonna read that out either
because i would
be i'm not sure i could do without
singing it and singing on
the stream has got me in trouble before
so yeah favorite muppet
um pepe
uh what are you drinking water
ah
i love this is just a bunch of money
python quotes showing up in the stream
this
this is fun batman villains you would
want to see done or read done in live
action movies i choose
iv but um though i like hardy's version
i wouldn't mind
another crack at vayne honestly i don't
know because most of my favorite
um batman villains that they haven't
done
are too low-key for a movie
like i love the vantrella quest i don't
know why
but i do but no version of the
ventriloquist
works for a film like
you you just you couldn't pull that off
and i would say the penguin
except that again the penguin
and i mean we're going to be getting a
new version of the penguin but the
penguin in general
at this point tends to work better as
window dressing
as a as an element of the world as
opposed to a focus
um and just because he he's at this
point largely just a gangster with a
gimmick
um and not a heck of a lot
else that again feels like a too low key
for the movies
would you rather be tied to a chair and
forced to watch the shining or the
exorcist i'd rather watch the exorcist
should i force my mom to watch rocky
horror with me again not if she doesn't
like it no
shouldn't force anybody to watch
something they don't enjoy
don't have strong opinions on muppets
but dislike the connotations
of pepe the most for obvious reasons
okay factor had the best performance and
a single story of doctor who mine is
capaldi and heaven
sent um
i mean that's right up there
i don't know like i i can single out
performances that i like but like i
don't
my brain doesn't rank like best acting
in the show
i i don't know i i don't categorize the
the episodes or the performances like
that you can only choose one fat bottom
girls or who wants to live forever
probably fat bottom girls have your red
rick riordan stuff i have not i've had
plenty of people recommend it
i have no idea for when i'll ever get to
it i've got
books i've been commissioned to read
that i
am trying to get through and trying to
find the time to re reading is
hard for me again
add brain um you know the
the length the lengths of stretches that
i can sit down and like just
read something are not as long as i
would like them to be
and so it's it can take time
uh do you think they were mixing up
muppets with looney tunes because pepe
le pew is definitely questionable
possibly yeah no pepe le pew has
interest i was talking about pepe the
king prawn
so yeah that's actually a good point
they might
they might have gotten something mixed
up there uh i doubt it
but have you listened to any more big
finish recently i have not
uh have you seen batman versus tmnt no
i'm so far behind on the dc animated
stuff it's starting to get embarrassing
what do you thought senator scissorhands
i watched it once
it's well made didn't connect with me
that hard though
i'm doing a watch through of all of
terry gilliam's films
we'll be watching brazil a bit uh early
seeing as
it's a christmas film i forgot that
there's a christmas element to brazil
ah do you watch epic battles of history
i've seen a couple i mean they're
they're
all right i appreciate what they do but
it was one of those things i was like
gotta watch all of these
uh do you watch broke canon by davis
i've started to
um yeah that's he does good stuff
what would you say the most rewatchable
doctor who episodes are
or you watch midnight for the first time
and it was better than i remembered
i find personally um
a lot of the two the best two-parters to
be very rewatchable
so um the empty child and the doctor
dances
um uh
oh god i lost it for a second there um
impossible planet in the satan pit
um the silence in the library and force
of the dead
uh those sorts of things i find really
really rewatchable
most of the best two-parters were in
davie's era now that i'm
thinking about it do you eat meat yeah i
do
i'm i'm not a vegetarian or am i a vegan
uh that's not a political stance that's
just
not a road i've gone down
uh i'm currently sat writing my
dissertation
so i'm wondering if you went to
university college and what you studied
um
uh i went i didn't finish
i bounced around a couple of majors uh
ultimately
i am a failed english major
so uh i i should not be anybody's
model for a higher education
uh would you go out as king george iii
for halloween
[Laughter]
uh and you see now i'm just kind of
picturing like
after the like on a normal halloween
because this year is but on a normal
halloween i can totally just picture
the kids take the candy and they go away
just sort of stepping out onto the porch
you'll be back
not sure if you heard there's a new time
lord victorious audio
with four coming soon glad they're
taking advantage of time lord victorious
being a huge event
even if it means money down the drain
see i haven't been able to keep up
with time lord victorious at all and as
it's
like i keep forgetting how far into it
everything is
like i it's exhausting for me to keep up
with these multimedia things
it really is i burn out very quickly
just even trying to parse everything
that there is
but like if
if somebody could send me like a gift
bundle
of everything i'd probably dive right
into it but like just trying to sort
through that
it's it saps my uh my enthusiasm
why do you hate ferris bueller's day off
because ferris is a little [ __ ]
that's why it is as simple as that he is
an insufferable
entitled prick
who just ruins the lives of people
around him
never faces consequences for anything he
does and we're supposed to root for him
and be happy for him
no ah he's a walking embodiment of upper
middle class white male privilege and i
hate him i hate him so
much
if they were going to make a broadway
musical about your life who would you
want to play you
i don't know who's currently acting on
broadway these days and like even if you
were asking me the movie version of that
i don't know
i'm also narcissistic and with
aspirations of acting
acting so i would go up me
i seem to be the only one who can't
stand john hughes's work i will stand by
the breakfast club
i feel like that one actually holds up
pretty decently
um as far as his things go and also
planes trains and automobiles
that holds up pretty well also most of
his other filmography though
uh it's not bad but it's very
of its time
uh look rohan i
there are certain things that'll that'll
set off my
irritation did i freeze up or
maybe jonathan groff could play you
uh do you consider yourself a fan of
sasha baron cohen not especially
no i'm not and like
i'm not a fan of
his style and approach because he's
basically tricking people
and even sometimes like with something
like borat
he is tricking people who make fools on
themselves and a lot of these are people
who deserve to be made full of
i still don't like that it just doesn't
sit
like i hate pranks as a general thing
and it's basically an entire
um approach to filmmaking based around
pranking people
and i just don't like that
it doesn't sit right with me have you
ever listened to jeff wayne's musical
version of war of the world
yes yes i have
it's weird it's very strange
it's interesting but it's very strange
you say you're not into chick flicks but
you like legally blonde and that's a
chick flick
look me saying i'm not into a genre or
broadly speaking doesn't mean i don't
like any of the films in that genre
i like love actually as well most people
would consider that a chick flick
but by and large most things you would
lump under that heading
i don't like or wouldn't care to see
are there any movies you disliked when
you first saw but then liked or loved on
a re-watch
um
i'm sure there have been i'm kind of
drawing a blank though
off the top of my head do you plan
or have you watched that ah the freaking
owl house it goes on disney plus the end
of this month
then i will start watching it
it might be slow going because i'm going
to try and watch it with my kid
so i'm not going to binge through it all
at once so we'll get through it at
whatever pace we get through it
what are your thoughts on gremlins
second one is better
significantly fight me
jeff wayne's war of the world may be
strange but it's amazing to see live
i'll believe that
what are your thoughts on misery that's
a good movie kathy bates
is so good in
everything she's amazing
love her love her so much
i believe uh that song of the sea should
be classified as a halloween
film since it's set during halloween is
it
i haven't rewatched that one in a while
i missed that
uh what are your thoughts on the disney
movie enchanted it's cute
this guy it's cute it's meta it's fine
uh every
any genre mashups you think there need
to be more of um
hmm not on top of my head
as a teenager i hated breakfast club i
was so mad that i was expected to relate
to those characters
like i do relate to various characters
in that to varying degrees but i get
what you mean
because that's kind of how i feel about
ferris so like i get i
i get where you're coming from on that
i've never seen the gremlin sequel can
you summarize it please
uh the first one but better and much
much much much much
much funnier uh
what are your thoughts on annie the
musical
i don't know it's like in my mind that's
like entry-level musical stuff and maybe
part of that is because
like it was a musical i was in in grade
school so i think of it as like
little kid sort of stuff it's hard for
me to take seriously
that's not really necessarily reflective
of the reality but that's just my
perception of it
did you pay to see mulan i did not
i debated it and then i saw the
reactions and the reviews come out and
go i know i'll wait
excuse me have you seen the stage
version of the breakfast club i had a
friend play bender with the subtext of
his aggression coming from
frustrations of bisexuality now
i've actually got a question for you
there is there a proper stage version
now i ask because i've been
in a stage version but what we did
was adapt the script the film script
um making like one or two adjustments
on a couple of things um because it
actually does adapt
pretty straight is there actually a
proper stage adaptation
of the breakfast club because if there
is i wasn't aware of it despite the fact
that i've been in a stage adaptation of
the breakfast club
i will be curious to see who people
think it was
that i played
have you ever encountered snakes in your
backyard not the backyard i
have now but yes uh historically i have
what part did you play in annie no part
i was just i was just in the chorus i
was just an orphan
uh any other beloved movies you hate you
mean aside from the shining
uh yeah probably have you seen tennant
nope
uh i'm not going to a movie theater you
nuts
uh see would you watch a doctor who
anime if one were to be licensed i mean
out of
morbid curiosity i would
but was it the janitor uh no we had a
female janitor actually
um you played brian you're saying that
so definitively
that it i'm starting to wonder um if
i've
said that at some in some previous live
stream i probably have yes
yes i played brian uh have you ever
heard any gilbert sullivan
if you haven't uh sat around the table
at insert u.s version of weatherspoon
singing uh never mind the why and
wherefore you haven't lived
i actually am familiar with gilbert and
sullivan when i was in
eighth grade um we did pirates of
penzance
i forget the name of i think it was
samuel he's like he's like
second in command behind the pirate king
he has no significant singing parts
that's actually my track record
oftentimes for musicals when i was doing
plays you know in high school and
college and beyond
i tended to get the largest part you
could have without having a significant
solo singing part
um first movie you ever saw
uh like at all i don't know the first
movie i was taken to to see in the movie
theater was the care bears movie
that i know um but
like first movie even viewing at home no
clue
i have no idea are you a fan of the
princess bride
as you wish yes i am
ah have you seen cobra kai
i haven't but i'm going to so um
liz and i just recently this past
weekend
um finished watching crazy ex-girlfriend
which had been our show that we watched
together when we
are together um and because
we uh only see each other
you know every now and then on on
weekends
we took our sweet time um getting there
carolyn why are you cringing what'll i
do oh no
um but anyways we finished up crazy
ex-girlfriend
and we were debating uh
a number of um
shows to possibly start watching
together after that we actually landed
on cobra kai we haven't started it yet
but that'll probably be next time i see
her
we'll start that uh favorite
gilbert sullivan song mine is i am the
very model of a modern major general
of information vegetable animal and
mineral i know the kings of england's
then i quote the fights historical from
marathon to waterloo and order
categorical
um that one's not copyright or it
shouldn't be so i should be able to get
away with that
um i don't know i
just kind of like i am the pirate king i
just
i'm a sucker for a piratey song anyway
so you know
uh favorite character or figure in greek
mythology
um
i don't know athena's about the only
decent
uh of the god characters the rest of
them are all pricks
what are your thoughts on mrs doubtfire
i haven't rewatched it in a
long time so i don't know anymore
um my memory of it is
on the positive side but i haven't seen
in a long time
what are your thoughts on 10 things i
hate about you lots of fun
vera i hate that character princess
bride oh
i'm sorry carowind oh i didn't realize
um courtney b vance who plays george in
lovecraft country is also incredible as
johnny
cochran in
uh oh i lost it
uh in people versus o.j yes he was he
was phenomenal what are your thoughts on
the sand lot
never saw it i love that i opened this
um one up to be a
like an ama like legitimately
um you could ask me whatever
you want and it's all still like have
you seen this
have you seen that what are your
thoughts it's all still entertainment
related
it doesn't matter if i open up the
question topics that's what the
questions always end up being i kind of
get an amusement out of that
what are your thoughts on ghost i've
only seen it once
um and it's fine
like it was weird seeing as an adult
it's it's odd to go back and see these
staples
of um you know the 80s and 90s
uh and and just kind of be like oh
so that's what everyone was talking
about
favorite depiction of satan in fiction
i'm actually kind of partial to
peter stormair in uh constantine
he's like after he's on screen you feel
like you need a shower
oh it's great uh
thank you carowind for um for being on
top of that
i i greatly appreciate it um
is it okay to fetishize actual religious
beliefs of past
cultures or is that tacky i feel like i
need to know precisely what you mean by
fetishize
because i i i feel like the way you
might be using that word could be
several different things
and so i'm not entirely sure what i'd be
answering
um broadly speaking
uh the federatization of
either older or um cultures that you are
outside of tends to bring more
problems than anything else
because usually that tends to happen
with a very superficial understanding of
what any of that stuff
meant or was um or you know a
picking and choosing a certain aspects
that really
interest you so it tends to lend itself
towards
issues in general
uh the the choice of words i did find
amusing though
considering what i might start shooting
after this is done
um i'll leave it at that i donate
because i love and respect what you do
thank you brian
thank you very much uh
let's see would any of the bad place
team count as satan depictions no
no what are your thoughts on an american
werewolf in london and the howling never
seen the howling
american werewolf at london is fun
um i felt like by the time i saw it i
felt like it had been a little over
pumped up a little overrated
what's the most obscure or underrated
fandom you've ever been involved with
huh
i don't know i'm honestly not too sure
oh the discord thank you very much
carolyn for
that reminder uh back in a quick second
folks
so this is i suppose my
time to plug the discord which is a perk
of the council of geeks
patreon uh it's a perk at a
fairly low level so you know just saying
uh favorite studio ghibli film not by
miyazaki
i haven't seen all that many outside of
the ones he's done i mean
probably great with the fireflies
man that's brutus brutal can i send you
the book of deceased
if you want to yeah sure
um no promises on when i'll read it
uh what is your take on the studios now
holding back on major properties like
bond till next
until next next year and leaving cinemas
with no major content
although they can be open in many
territories and are doing okay business
when they have it
it's all well and good to say studios
want to wait till the audiences can come
back in numbers
but what if in the meantime the theaters
are gone it's really
it's really complicated
because the honest truth is and i
hate saying this because i love going to
the movies i love the movie theater
experience
but it's my honest opinion that most of
these places
shouldn't even in places where they are
allowed to be open and operate
they shouldn't be they shouldn't be open
right now um and like i say that as
someone like the
my local movie theater is open and i'm
glad it hasn't gone out of business but
i'm not
going i no that's a terrible idea
with everything going on and so
i don't want to i don't want to say i
take the side of the studio
because part of the reason the studios
are holding out is because there's not
enough in it for
them to drop movies uh for
a limited number of open theaters uh and
that is
a completely selfish motivated thing but
like under the circumstances
i i don't think those theaters should
even be open
i'm sorry i i just don't and i say that
with a weight in my heart knowing that
well like the the movie theater
in the town where liz lives is shut that
is
like out of business it's gone we walked
by it this past weekend and nothing on
the marquee no posters up
lights out dead and that bummed the hell
out of me
but they still shouldn't be open i'm
sorry
they shouldn't
uh no worries if the answer is no but
would you take a commission to do a
video of yourself reading harry potter
and the portrait
of what looked like a large pile of
ash i don't know what that is
so i
i feel like i would have to look into
exactly what that is
and then say maybe
maybe uh how does moderating your
comments section work do you read every
comment or do you have help with it if
you have help how do you show the
workload do you get noticed when a new
comment is posted even under your old
videos
or do you have to look out for new
comments is it usually fun to moderate
or is it more of a chore okay a lot of
questions there
logistically the way moderating the
comments works first of all i'm the only
one who does it
um unfortunately the way that um
youtube is set up for somebody else to
have access to the comment moderating
full features i would have to give them
access to my entire account
and i'm not going to do that so it is
something that i need to do
myself um that said like i have a bunch
of stuff set up i have a bunch of things
that
a bunch of trigger words or phrases that
automatically flag comments to be
reviewed
um i can have it set up where i can
alert for every comment i don't have it
set up to do that because i get way too
many comments to do it
i look at the comment section pretty
much every day um
i wouldn't say i closely read every
single comment but i i probably glance
at every comment
and comments on old videos show up
the same as comments on new videos just
with the way that youtube's
page uh for managing that is set up
uh are there any more important things
in uh oh sorry there are much more
important things in life but which
delayed movie release has you most
annoyed about it
um i was probably most looking forward
to
black widow that's probably the one that
i'm i was the most oh
um but okay let me i'm back from the
discord
um okay i'm not shyamalan good director
if you say yes what a twist um
i'm not shyamalan
he is a he is a very limited director
like i i realized that watching um
the village because he's one of those
writer directors who
he does not write natural sounding
dialogue and the kind of dialogue he
writes
doesn't come easily to some actors
and what i realized watching the village
was that he's not an actress director
he doesn't know how to work with them
because like i was watching sigourney
weaver
say her lines in the village and i felt
like every single
line that she had the subtext like right
behind her eyes she was quietly
screaming for the love of
god give me some direction i don't know
how to work with this dialogue
i don't know how to read these lines
help me
um and he never did or that's the
impression i was left with
and having seen more movies from him
since then yeah i get the sense that
some actors click with what it is that
he writes in what he does like bruce
willis seems to know how to work his way
around
um m night shyamalan's work pretty
decently so does samuel
jackson so does um
james mcavoy and it's not a knock on any
actor who can't
like it's not a weakness to need
guidance from a director to wrap your
head around a character or dialogue
that doesn't make you a bad actor but
some actors
uh seem to naturally grapple with his
dialogue others don't
george lucas has the same thing george
lucas lucked out with his original star
wars trilogy that he just got a bunch of
actors that
knew how to read that dialogue and then
the prequels came out and bunch of
people like
god this dialogue sucks and the thing is
the dialogue in the prequels is not
really that much worse
than the original trilogy you just had a
bunch of actors who didn't know how to
work with it
that's the difference
uh because you're gorgeous and marry me
maybe flatter brian but no
no how are you so cute
naturally she said
covered in makeup and false lashes
clearly not naturally
what is your favorite movie of all time
ghostbusters
um would you say the problems with the
character of ferris bueller stem from
him being mary sue no i would say they
stem from him being an insufferable
prick
he has a horrible personality he's a
terrible
person that has nothing to do with being
a mary sue
he's just terrible he is an appalling
human being
that's not a mary sue issue all right i
gotta jump down to the bottom because i
was i was hanging out
higher up because um
i had uh super chats to get to but like
like i said i'm not i'm not trying to
catch every single
um every single question
so apologies um how to keep deep
depression at bay
and with the latest supreme court
justice thomas and alito on lgbtq plus
rights
um
i really wish i had an answer for that
i mean broadly speaking i am fortunate
in that i don't
i've never been diagnosed with
depression i don't have it as a
as a condition i have down days but i
mean
everybody does um
[Music]
as far as how to
how to find hope
or light
knowing what some of the existing
supreme court justices
um want to do
and knowing the positions that the
likely
new supreme court justice has taken in
the past
i don't have a way to fend off
depression
on that i don't because anything that i
would that i say
that is some form of it'll probably work
out and be okay
would be a lie
we are in big big trouble
and not just for the immediate future
we are in big big trouble for a
generation
we are probably going to be
in big trouble for the remainder of my
lifetime
that's the unfortunate reality
that the things that a
conservative supermajority in the
supreme court
is liable to do
or take away
are things that will not be undone
for decades
at this point the hope that i have is
that in my daughter's lifetime
things will get better
i have limited hope
this is the worst case scenario
that we are looking at right now
because
when when the court
has the makeup that it's going to have
that means that the
that conservatives in various
positions of power be it
uh states attorneys generals be it
governors be it senators
what have you can orchestrate
the challenges to the laws
that they want undone which
let's also be clear has already been
happening key parts of the
voting rights act were tossed aside a
few years ago
we lost net neutrality
which strictly speaking wasn't a court
issue
but this is the way things have been
headed for a while
with this likely makeup
of the court in place
they will challenge roe v wade
they will challenge gay marriage
they will try and put in place
restrictions and clamp downs on
transgender rights to try and ensure
that
trans people do not get
any more than what they what little they
currently have
this is
this is a video i might end up making
for the vera wild channel but
there's an issue of liberal complacency
which we are currently now reaping the
consequences of there is
a feeling in
that i've seen at play for a long time
among liberal people where they feel
like you know
when you have phrases like
being on the right side of history part
of the implication of a
saying like that means this is the
natural progression
of time i mean it's right and then it's
progressive
we assume that this is the natural
evolution of where things will
go and because a lot of liberals
especially white liberals
have a tendency to believe in
basically just love will win
like it's some sort of natural
result of the ebb and flow of the
universe
they tend to think well if we just wait
we'll get there
meanwhile the conservatives
aren't waiting they're fighting and
they're fighting actively
and too many people on the left side of
the aisle
are sitting back going well they're just
wrong they're just on the wrong side of
history they're trying to fight back the
tide yes
yes they are but they're succeeding
because you're not pushing back on what
they're doing
to fight that
i don't know if part of the problem is
that the last major
civil rights victory in the us
being that of gay marriage was one
with
minimal harsh political action
i say minimal and i mean that in recent
times because
stonewall was a riot gay rights started
as a riot
never forget it i don't
i don't care if the six people have to
hear it sometimes you have to throw a
brick
because they're gonna deploy a hell of a
lot worse than that
to clamp us down and other people
who have as much rights as we do or they
should
for crying out loud
so
we had the gay right to marriage
and that was a huge win i don't want to
downplay that but that
was one that felt like it was one just
because well
it's going to happen and it felt like it
just did
and there isn't enough emphasis on how
much
fighting has had to happen
for virtually every other major civil
rights
advancement that has ever happened the
civil rights movements of the 60s
people had to fight people had to be
willing to take
billy clubs to the head people died
for that and i was not taught
that
i think back to how i learned about
civil rights when i was in school
and it was presented to me as if
things were unfair people marched things
changed which is so sanitized
to the point that it's almost harmful
that i thought that it was just a matter
of people
marching and drawing attention to it
that's not what it took and even before
that
women's suffrage people died
for these rights
and the fact that a lot of people seem
unprepared to fight back
with anything close to the ferocity that
the right is
fighting to remove these rights from us
infuriates me
the right has never stopped fighting
because they have to
they know that they are fighting the
tide they know that they are fighting a
progression and because they know it's a
fight
they treat it like a fight
whereas a lot of liberals treat it like
an inevitability which can make us
complacent
which can put us in a place where we get
hung up
on our own personal morals of oh
i'm going to vote for ralph nader
instead of
al gore because i'm going to vote my
conscience screw your conscience
i don't care about your conscience i
care about the end
result what is the end result
of too many people voting third party
for ralph nader
instead of voting for al gore because
they didn't like him as an individual
and look let me be clear i didn't really
like al gore i don't like joe biden
i honestly really don't i have a ton of
problems with those guys with that guy
i don't like the fact that he's my only
other option am i going to vote for him
hell yes
because i care about the consequences a
hell of a lot
more than some
obscure pie in the sky idea of morality
of
holding on to the ideals he's we should
have better yes we should but we don't
this is the situation we have
and you can either actively do something
about it
i'm sorry if we can't make it perfect
but we can do something to at least stop
it from getting
worse
and anyone who is unwilling to do that
because of my personal morals
screw you because your personal morals
are not a shield for anyone
else who is going to be oppressed by
what is going on
i don't care if you can sleep at night
i care about people's lives more than i
care about your ability to sleep at
night
so that became a thing
welcome to my ted talk i say that i
don't think i'd actually be allowed to
get that public
goal in a ted talk
oh okay
ah there we go um
ever been to salem massachusetts i have
actually um
i've been to salem once i bought a
victorian style coat and a top hat and i
still have both of them
i actually did a did a photo shoot
in those couple years ago that i was
quite happy
with the results of um have you seen the
trailer for borat 2
no because i know i don't want to watch
the movie so i don't really
care to see the trailer okay since
you've seen the people versus
oj what casting choices did you think
were bad in that show
none that show was brilliantly cast
top to bottom what are your thoughts on
fight club
fight club is a bit of a bizarre
creation because it
it's it's trying to critique
something that it is also itself an
example of and it's one of those things
that's really difficult
to try and do american history x suffers
from the same problem
because to try and show the danger of
the allure
of somebody like tyler durden you have
to show how cool he is
and how appealing he is but by depicting
how cool and how appealing he is
you run the risk of people actually not
realizing you're critiquing that and
just saying
wow that's so cool which has actually
happened with fight club
clearly there are plenty of people who
don't get that tyler durden is the bad
guy
so like it's really hard to try to like
decide to do that to go i'm gonna
critique
the appeal of this dangerous thing but
if you depict it as appealing
which it is and it can be and it has an
allure but when you depict that you risk
actually hooking people in
to the ideology you're trying to
deconstruct i don't know what the
solution is
but it's kind of a fundamental problem
at the core of that movie it's well made
but like
i i don't know man uh keep the off the
cuff rants coming
i mean like ranter's gonna rant
that's uh that's the thing that'll
always keep happening
uh
let's see there was something that
came up i missed it um that was a bit
intense for me not gonna lie hey i
i can be uh intense
vera my favorite ring mistress oh thank
you carowind
ah let's see should uh nerd roddick
rename his
channel i i don't watch nerd erotic
stuff
so uh no comment
like i tr i try very hard not to start
beefs uh with other channels
there are plenty of channels out there
that i have big problems with
um some broadly philosophically some for
very personal reasons
because i've had people come at me
personally before but i try very hard
not to start
you know feuds between i hate
interchannel drama
i hate that there's a cottage industry
for it
ah i've been pulled into that crap a
couple of times and like ah
don't want it i would ask you to listen
to my audio series but it could break
you
if you want to send a link to my email i
might preview the
front end of it and try and get a sense
of whether or not i can handle it and if
you want to commission me to do it i'll
pow
i'll power through but you know just
know
no promises what are your thoughts on
fright night 1985 have not seen it like
there's a lot of holes in my 80s um
viewing because what you need to realize
is i'm an only child
most people my age um who
are like ah 80s because like yes
technically i was around in the 80s but
i was born in 82 so like i was
like a young kid and most of like 80s
culture was like it was too old for me
at the time and but the thing is most
people my age who like ah 80s it's
because they had older siblings
who filtered that stuff down to them so
if you get somebody my age who's like
really into 80s music or 80s movies odds
are good that they had older siblings
who they were absorbing that vicariously
through i didn't have that so i've got
lots of holes in my 80s
um some people call classic who the
golden age of doctor who
are we in the silver age or the bronze
age with knew who
uh i don't know i don't like i feel like
you'd have to see i would actually make
starting i would actually make the 80s
the entire 80s era of classic i would
call that silver age
who and i'd say we're in the we're in
the bronze age now
let's see as a very young person myself
every person of the youngest generation
i have met um
has shown support for lgbtq plus
my school had pride day where everyone
came in rainbows you know what
um thank you for that rowan
um because it helps me to be reminded
that and like
again we have to be careful not to let
this
idea become the young
people will sort it out for us because
they won't
but it's true that
the younger generations the ones coming
up and some of whom are
you know old enough to vote you're gen z
and
folks like that and you know my
daughter's
generation um they
every statistic shows that they are more
accepting
and more loving and
that does give me hope
i hate that first there's probably going
to be a whole bunch of stuff that
happens that they're going to have to
undo
they shouldn't have to do that
but there is still some comfort and some
hope
you know knowing knowing the acceptance
level among
younger generations so i i actually
really appreciate
you um you're bringing that up what's
your favorite
superhero tv show of all time i don't
know
um i suppose it probably would be
uh legends of tomorrow i really do get a
kick out of that
what are your thoughts on the karate kid
from 1984 solid movie
i uh i grew up on that one i actually
like the second one a little better
i don't know how controversial that
stance is harry potter
and the portrait of what looked like a
large pile of ash is a
novel in quotes written by written with
a.i
and words cannot define it oh dear
oh dear it's nice to remember trump lost
the election
even if you have to remember he won
anyway i mean
depending on my mood i can either take
comfort or get very bummed out
about that because yes he is he
and people who think like him are not
the majority
but they have messed with the system to
the point that they have power
regardless
so you know and that and that's not even
me being like oh they rigged the
election i
like the this they the system has been
designed
and has been shifted in a way that gives
a disproportionate amount of power to
people who are actually not holding the
mind
the majority beliefs in this country
that is simply reality
the people in power right now do not
represent most of this country
statistically they just don't
have you ever seen snow white tale of
terror i have actually
i saw that ages ago but yeah i did see
that
that's a weird movie um
what if you met every incarnation of the
doctor in real life that would be
amazing
sadly impossible now but that would be
amazing
uh you know what i was saying about
working out get jack shave your head
wear a mask do a silly voice go full
band on your country
uh they're really screwed up bane and i
i don't mean like they screwed up the
comic book character i mean they screwed
up their own take on him
because he has a point but they have to
make him the unambiguous bad guy
so he's also going to blow up the city
for no reason other than we need him to
clearly be the bad guy so that our
um our hero whose power is white
privilege
can beat him up and have it be okay
uh that was unnecessary
what's something your daughter knew and
taught you that you didn't know before
too many things to count
every day with that kid she's a she's
amazing
when you say the second karate kid do
you mean the sequel or the remake with
jackie chan the sequel
man crowded kid part two it's good
i like it not to be a pesterer but
here's your reminder for doctor in
distress
yeah i know uh owl house goes into
goes on disney plus on the 30th are you
going completely blind or are you aware
of some of the things that have happened
i know about some of the representation
that exists in it
i don't know which characters it's for i
don't want to know more than i already
know
uh yes h bomber guy pointed that out
don't think about wall street yeah
pretty much
pretty much um
been getting into hartnell stories
lately i admit to crying last night when
i watched susan's exit dalek invasion of
earth is a great story in general i also
enjoyed the aztecs
i think dalek invasion of earth is
probably my favorite that i've seen of
hartnell zera
i've gone over how long i usually do
this
i'm gonna i'm gonna wrap it up soon i
think
uh not a question but you look gorgeous
thank you morgan
thank you very much um
favorite classic literature treasure
island
uh can you review doctrine distress oh
for god's sake
now there's a chorus of you telling me
to do that
ah
yeah i was surprised that cuba gooding
jr travolta and schwimmer and nathan
lane
all delivered in that show i wasn't
surprised because they're all capable of
being very good actors but it was
very nice to see everybody on point in
that one
um
uh let's see i love your help
it looks like something an oregonian
would wear no
vermonter similar sensibilities
apparently
would you ever consider ranking the
buffyverse seasons in a video if you
haven't already
um i i did think about that but the
thing is most of my buffy videos didn't
perform exceptionally well
so i think i just kind of scrapped it
for that reason macintosh yes or no i
mean
i don't use max but that's because it's
not what i'm used to and i'm a creature
of habit
what are your thoughts on dirty dancing
and footloose never saw foot loose dirty
dancing is
the movie
vermont hey a bernie person
yes yes we do get to claim credit for
bernie did you watch the second american
crimes story series about
uh gianni versace i did not uh i didn't
get around to it
russell t davies originally wanted hugh
grant as the ninth doctor but he turned
it down
how do you think he would have done the
role um
i'm assuming probably not dissimilar to
when because didn't he show up in
um curse of the fatal death
i mean probably just that but tone down
slightly
like i actually like um
hugh grant i think he's kind of
underrated as an actor but he like
especially at that point in time he
still had like the stammery
charm thing i'm like man i'm i'm not
sure i'm
feeling that
i personally hated that lorca turned out
to be a villain
uh he should have just been a guy with
ptsd what are your thoughts
um
you're gonna have to forgive me i'm not
entirely sure what that's in reference
to
so what are your thoughts on christine
and cujo
more 80s movies i never saw i just
wanted to thank you for keeping me
company the last few months
it's been very much appreciated during
trying times you're welcome quinn
and thank you for watching
and also supporting because i i
i've had to put your name in my uh
in my credits so i i appreciate you too
am i the only person who thought that
gotham scarecrow the first actor
is rather underrated um
like when you say that do you mean the
kid or his father because
i i feel like that could go either way
uh you can't hire johnny conker and
that'll make you look guilty yeah but
you go home
oh that really was a good season of
television
what did what effect do you believe that
the large number of people that are
fighting furiously for lgbt rights
right now are having
anyone who is vocally supporting lgbtq
plus rights has a positive impact
because those of us who fall under
any of those letters we need to know
that people are
supporting what we do and who we are
and our lives and our existence
and we need to know that we are not the
only ones in this fight because it's
very easy to get
disheartening feel like it's you against
the world so anyone
lending any degree of support and
visible support especially
is helping in some way
uh i wasn't going to mention doctor in
distress this week
i will however recommend doctor who and
pirates
it's a musical there's pirates evil and
smythe and
vincent and the doctor-esque themes
i'm intrigued
yeah these have become a regular part of
my schedule and it's nice to have this
look forward to
been weird times is super comfortable
place thanks well
and thank you as well
uh let's see
just to know people give a [ __ ] about
give a darn about us under the lgbtq
plus community means the world it really
does morgan
it really does
um okay so i guess somebody clarified
that lorca is from star trek discovery i
don't watch star trek discovery
i don't have cbs all access
which i guess is getting rebranded as
paramount plus because paranoid
paramount can't have an original idea to
save its rear end
favorite story from each doctor oh okay
let's see if i can remember all these
um dalek invasion of earth tomb of the
cybermen the time warrior
city of death caves of andrew zani
i'm going to have to go with a big
finish because i don't like any of the
tv episodes so holy terror um
remembrance of the daleks knight of the
doctor
uh war doctor is going to be day of the
doctor more or less by default
uh so ninth doctor
is um the empty children that archer
dances tenth doctor
oh i go back and forth on this one
probably midnight
right now tenth i'm sorry eleventh
doctor is vincent and the doctor 12
doctors have been sent
13th doctors can you hear me there we go
you have a cute laugh thank you uh you
should watch
evil it recently came to netflix from
cbs for a limited time
i haven't even heard of that there's so
much stuff that keeps popping up on
netflix like here's this new show i'm
like another one
the hell do you people ever sleep
are there any musicals that you are fond
of my number one favorite is phantom of
the opera
oh yeah there's plenty i enjoy hamilton
i like phantom i like les mis
i like rent because i'm a little bit of
a theater basic
[ __ ] um i suppose the
the only thing close to a deep cut for
me is um
next to normal which i adore oh
that shows so good how do you call out a
transphobe without losing them
i mean
the the honest answer is i don't know
because
i
the thing is i have yet to have
really any notable in-person
confrontation
with a transphobe or somebody espousing
transphobic leaves to my face
i think it helps that i'm six feet tall
and
broad-shouldered i i feel like i
intimidate people enough
that they don't say stuff to my face
or where i can hear it but like the only
broad piece of advice i can give is if
you're actually genuinely trying to
reach out and have a conversation with
buddy is what i with somebody is what i
said in
the video about jk rowling that i did um
[Music]
a little bit ago which is
don't talk about transphobia in terms of
something that the person is talk about
in terms of something that they're doing
that something that they said is
transphobic something that they did is
transphobic
not wagging your finger going you are a
transphobe because that is pretty much
going to guarantee
that they clam up and get defensive
i'm not going to guarantee that they
won't get defensive doing it this other
way but there's at least a chance they
won't
so you know you take what you can
ian and barbara or ben and polly i don't
know ben and paulie very well i haven't
really gotten to their stuff
i like barbara ian annoys me ian's a bit
of a
bit much for me sometimes thank you for
saying that about the civil rights
movement
you're welcome and thank you for the for
the super chat i
greatly appreciate it have you seen
kinky boots movie or musical i've seen
bits of the movie i want to like it
but like it just isn't hitting
the the bits i saw didn't didn't really
do much for me
does it hurt to realize that rocket man
probably wouldn't have been the same
without kingsman 2.
no it doesn't hurt i can look at it as
the one good thing that came out of
kingsman 2.
god that movie sucked
i really did like hamilton however i
personally felt like hamilton's son's
death should have hit a lot harder
because i personally felt like he didn't
have enough
time on stage i will agree and disagree
i feel like the
actual spoilers for hamilton and
spoilers for history
the actual event
um of philip's death does not hit as
hard as it might but the thing is i
don't think it's designed to
i feel like it's the song that comes
after that the song it's quiet uptown
is where it goes for the emotional gut
punch of that and that i think is very
effective
so i'm not sure that's a bug so much as
the intended experience
that like you're watching this kid die
and like if that
could hit harder that wouldn't be bad
but like when they really go for the gut
punch it's the song
following so i don't feel like they
necessarily failed they just chose to
put the emotional emphasis at a
different point other than his actual
death if you follow me
uh if they cast you in a broadway
revival of next norm would you do it
yes yes i would
i want to play diane so much
who's crazy the husband or wife
can't sing any more than that uh what
are your thoughts on the movie bohemian
rhapsody
it was decent i thought it was pretty
good rocketman's so much better though
if i send you a link there may be a long
paragraph explaining some of the faults
just a warning like
fair enough uh
i don't like it as much as i feel like
but i'm always happy to see nick frost i
mean
nick frost really is he's he's like a
he's a warm mug of coco of a human being
did you know bearman played raul and
phantom back in the 90s i did not know
that
i was unaware i was today years old when
i learned that
thank you
i think this might be the one reason i'm
still going i've been
way slower drinking this than i normally
am
uh i'm about to start homeschooling my
son until kovit is over with and i
intend to make sure he knows about
stonewall
yes good call do you enjoy any web
comics i used to read sluggy freelance
back in the day
i i am several years behind at this
point
agree with you on the first and second
doctor stories third spearhead from
space fourth genesis of the daleks i
really do think genesis of the dogs is
overrated
um it's fine but it's overrated uh caves
avengers annie revelation of the dogs i
didn't like revelation of the dogs at
all
that one really ticked me off chris
fenwick decent that was pretty good
wait don't spoil history i'm not caught
up i'm told the nazis became recurring
villains
being bought brack and being brought
back in in increasingly stupid ways
yeah yeah
like when i tend to think of the fact
that of like some of the stuff that
we're
dealing with uh day to day especially in
the country in which i live
i can't help but think of two things one
the good place the other john mullaney
so the good place ted danson's kept
michael going
and there's nazis again now for some
reason
and then john mulaney basically
expressing the same thing with much
greater exasperation
and now there's nazis again i don't care
for these new nazis
and you can quote me on that i do enjoy
john mullaney quite a bit
why do you think shawn of the dead is
the weakest of the cornetto trilogy
i think uh well for two reasons one its
main core message probably speaks to me
the least
um and it it felt like the
in terms of theming it felt like the the
one that had the most
focused in on what would be cool whereas
i felt like the thematic threads became
stronger with each one
now i personally like hot fuzz the best
but you can
see how strong the thematic elements and
the core
themes of the thing got with each one
because
um world's end the theming is so
great in that movie it's phenomenal
so i like the progression of that and i
think shauna that has the weakest
theming it's not devoid of themes
and it's not absent of of decent theming
but certainly in terms of the three
uh do you like the five doctors i need
to rewatch it
i was one of the first classic uh error
things that i saw which means i saw it
before i had really kind of climated
to the experience of watching classic
who so i owe that one a re-watch
uh how can i feel affirmations without
you liking the same things i do
i suppose you will just have to take
comfort and joy in those things
unto themselves
aerosmith or acdz neither
there is a horse loose in the hospital
i have a i have a friend who said okay
kade i don't
know why you keep putting up the years
of
um stretches for
doctors i
like i don't i think i missed the
context for why you would post that
and you've done it now three or four
times so i feel like i'm missing
something
um but anyway the horse was in the
hospital thing i have a friend
um
um by the name of i got i have to put
the paws in here
uh he's a drag king his name is mike
oxredi who does a great
number that has though the
the bits of from horse loose in the
hospital interspersed across
um the panic at the disco song high
hopes
it's great i love mike mike's on tick
tock if you're on tik tok
find him he's wonderful
uh what are your thoughts on musical
bootlegs i
i don't really have any strong ones
heathers are mean girls or both i've
never seen heather's
another thing that passed me by is it
okay to enjoy something that expresses
views you're against oh yeah
i love 300. and i do not agree with any
of the views of the lead characters
and arguably the views that the film
itself is espousing but i
love that movie i own it i love it
it's great
uh read deceased yet no i don't have it
so no i'm getting i'm getting
like sassy with it
that might be a sign to uh to call it a
night
on popular opinion 42 is one of my
favorite filler doctor who episodes i
also believe prisoner zero is a
fantastic villain
okay i'm glad you take enjoyment from
those
uh it's a what if scenario where there
isn't a gap between
89 96 and 20 in 2005 oh
oh okay yeah that would have been an
interesting timeline
if they cast you as king george the
third in hamilton would you do it yes
they wouldn't but yes did you review
watchmen the
show from 2019 i still haven't seen it
i need to like i really did not that one
i need to
um but no i haven't reviewed it because
i haven't seen can i send dc's to you
if you want to i've got my p.o box
listed in the description
what did you like what didn't you like
about revelations of the daleks
the fact that the doctor does not
participate in the story
he spends the entire thing trying to
enter the building where the story
happens
and shows up at the very end so that
davorus can say this is somehow all the
doctor's fault when the doctor
does nothing like it's very typical for
the doctor to stumble onto a story
already in progress
i don't remember it ever happening that
he actually starts to participate in it
that late and have that little impact on
what's going on
ah i i i do need to wrap this up soon
that was a bit more of a chug than i
intended it to be
um
if i do send it to you will you send it
back i would kindly request that you
include a postage
paid uh return envelope
and then yes uh
can the video with my cavity if i
remember we'll see
water goes down that ah something has to
uh any previews for your last christmas
review it's one of my favorite capaldi
episodes
see like here's the thing
i've i've gotten so far ahead on the
uh on the take two doctor who reviews
that oh thank you channel pup i
appreciate that
but so like i've i've started watching
and shooting my reviews for series 10
so i i watched shot my review for last
christmas so long ago
i don't really remember what i said now
it'll be a refresher for me when i edit
it
which i need to i need to do this week
uh under the lake before the flood
floats between spots two and three on my
list of favorites where is it for you
it's it's i i appreciate it more after
the re-watch you'll have to wait for the
review on that
what are your thoughts on shrek 2001
um it was an important movie when it
happened doesn't hold up great second
one's better
uh last christmas the doctor who episode
or last christmas the rom-com
david and sean of the dead and carlin
ghost are both characters who
i don't think do anything that horrible
to deserve the punishment
um i mean yeah there's conversations to
be had there
i used to think you were crazy about
tennant not being the best
the more i rewatch them the more i see
it why did you plant the idea in my head
vera leave me an ignorant bliss i i'm so
sorry that i made you
think critically about media you enjoy
i'm so sorry i'll never do it
again
uh what are your thoughts on ice age
it'll keep kids occupied for 90 minutes
that's about it
it's kind of sad i bought the cavalier
box set and still haven't washed it
after three months you should
you should please forgive me if this is
personal since you have long hair do you
wrap your hair in a towel
yeah usually at least briefly um
and then when i then when i take it out
i just give a little bit of that
to to emphasize the waves and the curl
uh no product in that that's just what
my hair does
uh so yeah there we go i think i'm gonna
wrap
scrat alone is worth it like scrat
belongs in shorts
he doesn't save the rest of the movie
okay
but thank you very much for watching
this went ooh
dang about a half hour longer than it
normally does
and now you flood me with more questions
um
getting good with my lightsabers i'm
almost there oh that's exciting donna
and thank you very much i appreciate
that
ah so
i am going to wrap it up for the night
thank you all for joining me
and through sticking around through um
me trying to keep up with questions and
for um setting through a
what probably about 10 minutes of
incredibly political material
um and for
just being with me
like i it matters
it helps a lot i really do look forward
to
these and i i know things got serious
there for a bit but i don't think
there's been a time
when doing this hasn't
given me a little uplift so thank you
everybody for
coming i hope you have a great rest of
the week
i wish you well and until next time